Hãy về tâm anh chỉ khai sách dễm viêm càn đêm miếng phi trong người viêm càn bề mạng tính,
dút tâm sốt viết cơ sĩnh tới sự gàn, ông thương gàn sống.
Thào các trường ra, viên rút về viêm càn sự viên đây,
hát đe vê, là lại viên rút viêm, chỉ tính công ở vừa đa nhiễm viêm càn bê,
tuổi tốt bộ tình chính sự gàn và ủ tương gàn tâm nhân gấp hai đến bà lần.
Hãy, Việt Nam có khoảng 18 việu viêm càn bề nhìn chưa tưởng tâm sốt viêm càn sự viên đây.
Hãy đi lần những kiêu quy mô lần nhất tại Việt Nam về viêm càn đây,
đều tri khai đa chung tâm tâm tại mình Việt đã qua tâm anh trên tòan khó,
và mình định bệnh mai từ tháng 15 năm,
hành hủ chăm 20 năm, đến tháng 15 năm, hành hủ chăm 20 sau.
Nhằm giúp về mẹ đồng viêm viêm càn bề và đe có thiêm cơ hối phát hiện sống.
Chú động gán tránh viết cơ sơ gàn và ủ tương gàn.
Đây cũng là bước trình bị quan trọng để hề tâm ít tế trong lước sáng sàng
tích định và tri khai các tốt đều chỉ đặc hiệu viêm càn đây trong tương lai.
Đồng thời mọi giống khả năng tích cận thuốc mới và năng cao năng lục trình đón
được chỉ mạnh viêm càn theo chọn cúc tế.
Lối tự tháng ra là người tư mề sáo tùi trở lên đã được trình đón viêm càn bề mặt tính.
Mô người chỉ cần thăm khám một lần để được lấy mẫu sức hiện nhằm phát hiện viêm càn đây
tòan bộ chi vì trong phạm viêm kiểu được miếp phi và có hỗ trợ một phần chi vì đi lại.
Để thực hiện viêm kiểu theo chọn cúc tế, viêm kiểu tâm anh,
bình Việt tâm anh đã đồ tư hệ thống trong tiết địa sẽ kiện truyền dụi hiện đại chỉ giá hàng trục biệt.
Cung chung tâm sẽ phó bệt, tế bảo đà tư trình xi ai p và a sâu.
Chào tiết địa hiện đại, nhằm phục vụ trên đón và đánh giá có mẹ lý gàn mật.
Đừng uống bác sĩ, ký thật viêm được truyền dạc 10 phó tri tiếp đào tạo ký thật xếp viêm càn đây
theo truyền 10 phóch, đà bảo độ trình xác và chất lượng cục tế,
bình Việt tâm anh có năng lục sấn đau về xế dựa, phần tích trường xấu,
bệnh nhân đồng những viêm càn bề và đây, bác sĩ sẽ sử dựa giữ lượng được chỉ phu hợp.
Chú đồng kinh sốt viết cơ, sơ gàn, bảo vệ sức khỏe lâu dài trong người bệnh và cộn đồng.